hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well chapter 7 of
Aristotle's categories is devoted to
quite a lot of discussion of one very
important category which we translate as
relation in the Greek it's prostie and
prose is a pronoun which which
significant p of course is sort of an
indeterminate thing is in relation to
whatever so I am you know looking at
this book I am the looking is in
relation to this book or if I am in the
position of lecturer right now and
you're in the position of audience
audience and lecture are what we call
core relative terms so if you say the
audience because it will the audience of
what right the audience of the show the
audience of a podcast the audience of
the video the audience of some guy
getting up on the proverbial soap box in
the middle of town and ranting and
raving each one of those is a term that
would be in relation to the audience and
the audience would also be in relation
to that term those are what we call
correlatives and we'll talk about that
in just a moment first we want to think
about well what does it mean to actually
talk about something as being a relative
and we could talk in terms of relative
firms that is linguistic units that are
signifying something relative or we can
think of something being relative it's
very being what it is for it to be what
it is being relative and Aristotle
characterizes it's early on and really
consistently throughout this entire
chapter in in two complementary ways so
the one is talking about being of
another and so this is you know it's
what we call the genitive case we don't
really have this in English the closest
thing that we would say is the
possessive case and and you know we use
that advice we signify that with the
apostrophe s so-and-so's father right
that would be along those sort of lines
but to be to be of another to be from
another to derive from another the
team's mascot right the mascot is the
mascot of a team and presumably some
time way back in the team's antiquity
somebody decided that would it would be
the Bulldogs rather than the bullets
rather than the Bombers right so that's
one way of thinking about this of
relation that we we talked about in
terms of the genitive case in in Greek
has the rule and I to be of another to
be from another to be in relation to
another then we have something we could
call more strictly speaking being in
relation to another pros heta Rome has
her own is just you know something else
right or another and we have that pros
there so Aristotle saying it's not
always going to be signified in exactly
the same way we have to do a little bit
of mental analysis from time to time in
order to pick out relative terms and
it's important to be able to recognize
relative terms and not to mix them up
with other things other categories like
that of substance or the at of quantity
or that of quality
because when we do that we wind up in
all sorts of metaphysical and and
logical predicament and confusions so
it's important to get this down now I
want to bring up a few points that will
be discussed at greater length in some
other videos Aristotle talks about all
relatives by their very nature having Co
relatives that is things that are in
relation to them this is unavoidable
because you can't really have a relative
term without having a correlative and
when we look at some of the relative
terms we'll see why this is the case not
all caught all relative terms have
contraries some of them do Aristotle
uses an example here that's probably
going to be a bit confusing namely that
of virtue advice in part because virtue
and vice are also going to get talked
about in the category of quality here
he's thinking about them in terms of
habit and habit will get to that in a
moment some admit of degrees so if we
use you know for example a greater or
same or similar you can say that two
things are more similar to each other
than they are to something else or that
they're less similar so for example I go
back to my frequent use of chalk these
three pieces of truck are more similar
to each other than this piece of chalk
why because these pieces of chalk are
actually you no longer and this one's
been used quite a bit for writing so
it's a little bit shorter and it also
has some rounded edges too now that said
these two pieces of chalk are more
similar to each other than this shorter
piece of chalk is that one would
actually be more similar to this piece
of chalk here you get the idea we can we
can speak in terms of degrees of a more
and and left we can do this with other
things
as well but this doesn't work for every
single relative term neither does
contraries work for every single
relative term but all of them will
indeed have Co relatives so now let's
look at some of the examples that
Aristotle is going to use so double
right why is double a relative term well
double of what right you could say you
know that this is a double piece of
chalk that's a weird way of talking
about it we it's probably stricter you
know or more rigorous to say there are
two pieces of chalk here perhaps they
actually came from a single piece that I
broke and I can say well I doubled it I
doubled the amount of chalk pieces but I
didn't actually double the amount of
chalk and you know so we see that this
is a term that requires us to to relate
it to something else double of what you
know this is ty if I fold it double now
there's twice as many fabric pieces
right we can go on and on and on with
examples of that you know any sort of
number term along those lines now notice
that that that term is not quantity
where you might expect to see it for
Aristotle but rather in relation why
because Aristotle is picking out you
know the feature of that which is that
it exists in relation to something else
greater greater or lesser these these
terms that we use to signify again
things that look like quantity but are
really more a matter of requiring a
reference to something else are a matter
of their they fall into the category of
relation so greater right greater than
what this is where interestingly we see
we run into problems if we talk about
bigger and smaller right a hill is
bigger than a human being but much small
than a you know continent right you you
can only specify these these terms by
bringing up something else same or
similar or anything else along those
lines like dissimilar unlike like those
require a reference to what the thing is
actually like in a great example of this
if we get away from visual examples
think about describing teeth notoriously
difficult to do quite subjective and as
we're finding out some of its kind of
made up on the fly right you'd swing
some whiny say all I taste oak and
leather and you know the cologne that my
friend's parents used to wear back in
1986 so that's getting very subjective
but you get the idea if you're saying
that it's like those sorts of things
then you have to specify you can't just
well it like and then just leave you
know dot dot dot after that because it's
not like anything then right if you
think about other flavor profiles like
when you when you a great example when I
was a kid we had a bubblegum explosion
at first there was just bubblegum and it
was bubblegum flavored I don't even know
what bubblegum flavor really is just
kind of sugary and I'm sure there's some
fruit flavor that that's in there mixed
in there somewhere and then suddenly you
know Bubble Yum and hubba bubba came out
and they had grape flavor and orange
flavor and you know some things that
weren't quite so good like chocolate
flavor and and and on and on and on and
on and on alright so if you want to say
when you're saying those flavor things
you're saying it tastes like this if
it's watermelon flavored gum it is gum
that has the same taste as that that
watermelon right and oftentimes it's
interesting
because there can be kind of a reversal
where people who are so used to
artificial flavors get used to the
artificial flavors and they use that as
the primary point of reference in the
relation and they say they taste the
watermelon they're like this doesn't
taste the way a watermelon should and
you're like buddy that's the watermelon
right there the gum you've been chewing
or the you know slurpees or whatever
you're used to are not the actual thing
that is related to derived from
similarly with orange or root B or
anything along those lines so those are
all fairly straightforward then he
brings up an example that he uses quite
a lot and there's a lot to be said about
Aristotle and slavery we don't need to
go into that right now but he's going to
use that as an example of a term you
don't get a slave without also having a
master and the word slave is throwing
you think servant and employer or
something along those lines right parent
is not a term that he uses but he uses
this in other places great example you
cannot be a parent without there being
some sort of child whom you are in
relation to right you see people posting
these these things to be a clever or
cute you know when they're giving their
profile I am the parents of this person
right so they define themselves as you
know Susie or Tommy's father or so and
so's husband or so and so's why for our
mother or grandmother or whatever right
those are relational terms all of those
are in relation to each other so those
provide us with some great examples now
Aristotle brings up another set of
relational terms that are a little bit
trickier for us to wrap our heads around
habit and disposition which is actually
going to discuss under the category of
quat of quality the topo zone which is
in the next chapter here he's discussing
it but he's not discussing it in terms
just as had
which heck states or disposition DSA's
per se he's thinking about it about that
of relation the habit of right so if i
have a virtue like the habit of
generosity allows area in greek also
translated liberality or freedom then I
I have a habit and the habit is
specified in relation to certain things
you have it is the habit of behaving and
feeling certain ways knowledge right
knowledge is of something so if I if I
know Aristotle meaning i understand
Aristotle's text and what's being talked
about in them I don't just have
knowledge per se i have knowledge of
this thing if I know how to unclog a
drain you know very very rudimentary
level plumbing that is knowledge not of
Aristotle text but of unclogging drains
or perhaps of pipes if we want to say it
that way perception similarly you're
seeing this green book hopefully you're
not red green colorblind in which case I
don't know what color you're seeing
there but it's not what I'm seeing both
of us are seeing this book perception of
the object the color the thing that is
being experienced if I taste the book
doesn't taste like anything really no no
real flavor profile there chalk you know
I remember tasting that as a kid not a
good thing to taste definitely chalky
right perception of something position
here the term that he's using is safest
meaning where something is is being set
or the act of setting something and
there is a category of position or or
condition or however we want to
translate it in that case it's not
exactly the same term its case sigh
which is from that same word and that's
the sort of passive verbal form of the
verb for putting things in place
a little bit of you know strangeness
about the the Greek language in this
that we don't really need to worry about
here but I does want to say look
standing sitting all those sorts of
things those are being positioned in a
certain way but position itself is in a
certain respect a matter of relation
setting this here right so those are all
examples and you see just how much scope
this category of relation hit the last
thing that I need to mention and I'll do
another video discussing this in greater
detail is that no substances or parts of
substances are relations or relative
terms according to Aristotle it was a
very important point the relationship
between you know say teacher and student
where you can't have a teacher without a
student or you can have a student
without a teacher is not the same thing
as the relationship between hand or head
to use the examples that Aristotle
brings up and the substance human being
Aristotle gives you some explanation of
this basically what it comes down to it
what will say at this point is that the
the thing is a substance and it's not
being defined as hand just in relation
to me doesn't exist as a hand only in
relation to me now of course if you cut
off the hand it doesn't it's no longer
acting as a hand as an organ of this
this body it'll die it'll turn into them
but it still remains hand in if we ask
about what what is what is what is this
thing what is it for it to be what it is
hand is essential to it or part of its
substance and you know now the hand of
course can be in relation to other
things I can put my hand into my pocket
that's really more of a matter of
position though that or actually even
like you know more similar to is armed
is shot than it is relation
the hand of course could be involved in
perception in which case we're not
considering it so much his hand but
considering it as the organ of touch so
all of these are things to keep in mind
as we look at the category of relation
in chapter 7